comme chaque mercredi notre séquence
consacrée au travail d'une association
gros plan ce midi sur la section marche
nordique de l'ess et et et orléans une
section dynamique qui compte 120
adhérents encadrés par sept animateurs
tous bénévoles et formé à la discipline
car vous allez le voir la pratique de la
marche nordique ne s'improvise pas
isabelle racine et florie content so ont
suivi ces marcheurs avec leurs bâtons
allez on y va
ça commence toujours comme ça allez on
lève bien les talents si vous voulez
bien
on s'échauffe ce didier la marche
nordique est une activité dynamique et
c'est pas une activité plan plan le ton
est donné dans la bonne humeur toutefois
car voilà la marche nordique
ce n'est pas une simple balade avec des
bâtons c'est assez technique
ce qui est important c'est le grand pas
le planter ou au travail
les biceps les pectoraux les abdos et
dans la phase de poussée en fait
travailler l'arrière du bras les triceps
et les muscles du dos donc c'est
vraiment mais pour ça il faut bien
planté bien pousser la marche nordique
est née en finlande dans les années 60
en france
on la pratique surtout depuis une
dizaine d'années roger lecomte était
déjà là il ya sept ans quand lie ce que
tu étais a créé la section marche
nordique en mains des bras voir derrière
la shon élégant bipèdes
aujourd'hui ils sont sept animateurs et
propose deux séances par semaine à leurs
120 adhérents
nous souhaitons qu effectivement les
pratiquants est un bon geste là ils vont
pouvoir bénéficier pleinement de
bienfaits de cette activité ont fait
système musculaire système cardiaque
système respiratoire
on en profite aussi pour faire un peu
travaillé dans le bon sens et
articulations et puis on se vide aussi
l'esprit donc c'est très bon pour lutter
contre le stress et autres
la marche nordique c'est une activité
qui fait du bien à l'esprit et au corps
80% des muscles sont sollicités
allez jean claude emmène bien tes bras
derrière qui n'est bien vos bâtons on
n'a mal nulle tard on n'a pas
l'impression de forcer et quand on a le
bon geste
et ben voilà ça ça muscle c'est
formidable ça me permet de marché d'une
façon plus contrôlée de me concentrer
ça m'apporte aussi un renfort musculaire
et puis
ou un bien-être je crois que ce sera du
bien-être moi je conseille ce sport pour
tout le monde qu'on peut faire le disque
à x années
après deux heures d'efforts la séance se
termine avec les indispensables
étirements
[Musique]